- What's up Believe Nation?
It's Evan.
My one word is "believe" and I believe
that you have something
special to offer and I'd love
to see it explode so that you
can help change the planet.
So to help you on your journey today
we're going to look at
seven different ways
that you can make business alliances.
- [Robotic Voice] Nine...
Eight...
[Upbeat Music]
- So one of the fastest
ways to grow your company
is through alliances.
You find people who are already selling
to your target market and instead of you
having to go one, by one, by one, by one,
talking to potential customers
you want to be able to talk
to one person, who then
could open you up to tens,
hundreds, thousands, hundreds
of thousands of customers.
And so today I'm going to talk about
seven different ways
to be able to do that.
[Upbeat Riff]
Way number one is to look
at where do people buy
before they buy from you?
So understand that buying is a cycle.
People are not always
ready to buy from you.
People are not always ready to buy
from you potential alliance
partners and there's a phase
where you buy one thing from somebody
and then you graduate
and buy the next thing,
and buy the next thing and
so what you want to look at
is wherever you are in that buying cycle,
you want to find all the
people that your customers
are buying from before they buy from you.
So as an example, if you
are a graphic designer.
You know, you're a graphic designer
and you want to figure
out the buying cycle.
Maybe before somebody buys
graphic design services,
they have built a website
or they've got hosting,
or they've just incorporated a business
and so all of those people here,
you want to start making connections with.
You want to take them out for lunch,
you want to approach them, grab a coffee,
understand them and you want
to learn about their business
and it's way easier to set up a meeting
with a potential partner because
you can help each other out
much more that it is to make a cold call
and try to get a meeting with a customer.
And so I'm trying to
understand these people.
I'm trying to figure
out how I can help them.
If you get business that you
could potentially give to
them, that's great, right?
If you now know somebody
that needs website design,
or needs hosting or business
set up, you could refer them
to these people and also you're hoping
that if you make a good impression,
they could refer business onto you.
And understand that sometimes
you need to work out
a relationship with a
commission or a fee structure
where they get a flat amount
in they refer you a client,
or they get a percentage of a deal
if they refer you a client.
A lot of times they do this just because
it makes them look good.
It's a value added service.
If I'm a web hosting company,
and I've just taken on
a new client and I know
they need graphic design,
if I introduce them to
somebody who does a great job,
it makes them look good.
So if you do a great job for your clients,
anybody that's been referred in,
it actually makes that
person look great as well
and you're going to get a lot
more deals coming through.
So understand who the
people are that your clients
are buying from before
they ever buy from you.
Get to know them, take them to coffee,
understand their business and try
to find a way to work together.
[Upbeat Riff]
Way number two is to
understand where people
buy from after they buy from you.
So, we understand where
they're buying from before,
obviously then they're buying from us.
What's next?
Who is out in this range?
So if I'm a graphic designer,
and I'm making people
a beautiful business
card, well what's next?
They're going to need a printer.
So what I'm going to do now
is go and meet all of these people,
because these are all
potential alliance partners
for my business as well.
I want to talk to all
the printers in my area.
I want to talk to
anybody who they're gunna
then take my graphic design services
and do the next step with.
I want to talk to those
people cause again,
one, it's easy to make those meetings
cause those partnerships
you could potentially
help both of each other out.
It gives you a path to
refer your clients onto,
and then if clients are
going to them and saying
"hey I love your printing
services, but before we use you
we need to get a good graphic
design concept completed
for our business card," right?
They could then pass it onto you, right?
And if you do a good job
then you make them look good.
So again the same idea of
do you want to give them
a commission, a flat fee or just be able
to pass those frills
back and forth and have
that kind of trusted relationship.
Meeting with people on
both sides of the equation,
and forming as many
partnerships as you can
can really help explode your customer base
much faster than going after
customers one at a time.
[Upbeat Riff]
Way number three to make alliances
is through your customers.
A lot of times your customers
can be great conduits
for either becoming a business
partner in your company,
passing referrals onto you,
doing a tighter kind of integration with.
In my first software company,
we always used our customers
to fund our next development.
So we had our base software,
and then if a customer wanted
a custom feature built, we
would charge them for it.
Like, okay, you want that thing added?
Great, we can do it and
it's going to cost you
this amount of money.
We would do it at cost.
We wouldn't really make a ton of profit
off of that development,
but then that feeds into
our product and we can sell to everybody
and so any time any customers wanted
that custom integration,
custom development,
we would do it and it
helps everybody else.
So they're helping fund
our business to grow.
On my YouTube channel, as an example.
When I wanted to promote
my book, we reached out
to a number of you guys
that had YouTube channels
that were already a part of the community.
You guys are my customers and we're doing
some business development with and see
how we can help each
other out and I appeared
on your channel, you
appeared on my channels
and so there's a lot of
ways to make it work.
If I look at at Toronto
Dance Salsa as an example,
we look at the companies
that people work at
and often the students
who come in then take
the message back to their
company and they tell
their friends and they might put up a sign
in the lunch area and
help promote the school
and talk about us on
social media, you know,
so you want to basically get as close
to your customers as possible.
You want to understand
why they came to you,
what their needs are,
what they do for a living,
what makes them tick, what
their needs, passions,
desires are and one: that just helps you
get more referrals, right?
If they know you, like you, trust you,
they might tell their friends about you
but it could also lead
to a greater integration
with what they're doing.
It may lead to a tighter relationship
with the business that they're at.
More sales, more orders.
Introductions up the line.
When I had my software
company, another quick example.
So we got one scientist
at Johnson and Johnson
to buy our software.
Johnson and Johnson's a huge company.
They have tons of scientists
and so we want to really
get to know that person and
see how can we use that person
to get introductions to
the other scientists?
And then you get all the
scientists in that one area.
Then how do you use those guys
to leap frog to another area
and so soon you're getting
more and more and more
and more and more of the company.
Now you can't do that with every customer
but the more you understand
each individual customer you have,
then you can try to figure out
is there any kind of
relationship that we can have
to help grow this business together?
[Upbeat Riff]
- Tip number four is to use social media.
So I wanted to build a list of
potential alliance partners.
The first thing I did was
to reach out to people
who are already familiar with me.
I have a series called
"Unlocking Lily" on this channel.
I reached out to people who
are commenting on my videos
to do possible collaborations.
The second thing I did
was to reach out to people
who have reviewed Evan's book
or interviewed him on their channel.
That way we have a
mutual interest as well.
And the third thing that
I did was to go through
Evan's videos and to read
the comments of the people.
And there I looked at people's comments
that resonated with me and
I looked at their channel.
If they had an "About"
page I looked at what
they were about to see if
we align with our mission
and we could work well together.
From there I was able to create
my list of a thousand names
and I had some great collaborations
and even out of that I
made some great friends.
So to build alliances on social media,
the number one thing you want
to do is create a big list.
Mine was a thousand.
The more names you have, the
more possibilities you'll have.
Number two is to find
people that already know you
and who are already following you
and number three is to find people
who have similar interest as you.
If there's certain videos
that you love to watch,
look at the people commenting.
Chances are they're on
the same mission as you.
[Upbeat Riff]
- The number five way is
though your suppliers.
Think about all the people
who you are currently spending money with.
People who you are paying
on a regular basis,
whether you're buying a
product or service from them,
and see if there might be a
way that they could help make
introductions for you to other people
that might help your business.
So an easiest case example is looking
at lawyers, accountants, bookkeepers.
These are people who deal with
a lot of different entrepreneurs.
A lot of different kinds of businesses.
And so if they know what
your business is about
and they know the kinds of partnerships
that you're looking to make,
just letting them know.
You know, this is somebody
who you might be paying
once a quarter, maybe once a year.
Maybe more frequently if
you have more business,
but they have a vested interest
in helping their clients come together
and form greater relationships
because if you do that
then they're going to
make more business, right?
Like, you're going to come back.
You're going to give them referrals.
If you're looking at people
that you buy supplies from.
You know, if you're
buying t-shirts from them
and you're putting a big order
every month to buy t-shirts,
is there anybody that they may know
that could potentially help your business?
Like what is the kind
of alliance partnership
that you're looking for in an ideal world
and do they have somebody that
they could introduce you to?
And so it doesn't hurt to make
a list of all your suppliers.
All the people that you're
spending money with.
Now, if you're spending thirty
bucks a month on, you know,
Verizon to get internet,
I'm sure they're not going
to really care about helping you out.
And so the easier ones
that when you're dealing
with a person, you know, an entrepreneur,
or a physical sales person at a company
and you have a relationship with them.
Learn to tighten that relationship.
Get to know them.
Take them to coffee.
Have a lunch with them.
Understand what they're after to.
And try to figure out how you might
be able to help each other out.
Suppliers can be a fantastic
alliance partnership for you.
[Upbeat Riff]
Way number six is through
banks and governments.
And I put these two together
because they're both
low leverage typically
but it really just depends on the person.
And so when I first just
got started in my business,
I went to the bank and I said
"hey, I'd like some help."
And he said "well do you need a loan?"
Uh, I dunno if I need a loan.
I just got started.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I need help.
So that's not what banks really
do but it was with somebody
who was nice enough to then
put me on to somebody else
who then became one of my
first mentors in my business.
So again, banks see people all day long
who are potentially able to
make connections for you.
A lot of people don't
even know their banker.
It's a good idea just in
general to get to know
who your banker is cause
if you ever need money,
if you're ever trying to get
any kind of debt facility,
that personal connection
makes a big difference
but they may also be able to refer you
to other clients that they have.
Again, it really depends
on the individual.
Sometimes individual
bankers are really friendly
and really customer
focused and really driven
to help their clients succeed.
Other times bankers just
want to climb the ladder,
they hate this job, they want
to move up to the next step.
They don't really care
about their clients.
And so it makes it harder
to form that relationship.
Government, on the other
hand, a lot of governments
have different programs in place.
In Toronto, as an example,
we have a group called
"Enterprise Toronto."
It's funded by the city.
It has multiple locations
here and you can walk in
and get help with your business.
They have advisors who
try to give you feedback.
They will help assess your business plan.
They have multiple different
programs where you can apply
for funding and different opportunities
but they also try to connect you together.
You get to know the resource manager.
At Enterprise Toronto,
they may have mentors
they can connect you to, they may remember
another entrepreneur
that came in last week
that might be a good potential fit for you
and so it really depends on
what's happening in your city.
You may be fortunate enough to have a lot
of good government programs.
You may have nothing.
So that may not be a path for you.
So put banks and government together
because it really depends
on the circumstances
and who you end up being
able to connect with
but it's at least worth
exploring to see if there's
an opportunity for you to
make an alliance partnership.
[Upbeat Riff]
And number seven, my last way
to form alliance partnerships,
is through targeted events.
I'd be looking at where my
ideal partners are hanging out.
What kind of events they're going to
and go to those events
to get to know people.
So if you're looking at making
a partnership with people
who are, you know, techies who
are really into programming.
You want to have a custom development shop
as an alliance partner,
then you want to hang out
at the events that they care about.
Even if it's not super
relevant to you, right?
Like, you may not care
anything about programming
and the latest PHP development
and all the stuff that's coming out.
You don't care about that, but they do,
and they're hanging out there so you want
to go there and get to know them.
Whether that's a conference,
whether that's a meet up group,
whether that's some local
event that's happening
in your city, if you know
your target partners...
This is marketing 101.
If you know your target
partners are gunna be there,
you want to be there to get to know them.
And the advantage is of you being there
is a lot of times the
people who are like you,
your competition, is not gunna be there.
The people who are gunna be
there are more people like them.
Their competitors, who
may not want to talk to
and do deals with, but this
outsider comes in promoting
this different option that
is potentially complimentary
to them, you stand out
in the sea of similarness
and people will want to talk to you
and it's a competitive advantage.
Versus where you might go.
If you're a marketer, you
might go to marketing events.
You're like everyone else there.
If the programmer came there,
he would have an easier time
making those connections and
so hanging out is for talking
to customers too, but
hanging out where the people
who you want to talk to
are, even if it's outside
your comfort zone or where
you would normally go
is super important because that's how
you're gunna get the connections.
So those are my seven tips
on how to form alliance partnerships.
Again, forming alliances
is one of the fastest ways
to grow your company
because you're thinking
"I want to target one
person, or ten people,
or a group of people who
then could introduce me
to tons of people."
The goal is not to go after
one customer, one customer,
one customer at a time.
It works but it's not very
efficient of effective.
Where if you talk to the
people who could make multiple
introductions for you,
you're much more likely
to hyper explode your business.
So I'd love to know what you think.
I'd love to know which one
resonated the most with you
that you're gunna try and
apply to your business ASAP.
If you're going to add an
eight, nine, ten to the list
leave it down in the comments below.
I'd love to hear that too.
Now I made this video because
"I AM OMAR" asked me to.
So if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
on a future "7 Ways" video,
check out a link in the description.
Go there, cast your vote.
Have your say and I just might do it.
Finally I wanted to give a quick shout out
to Daniel from the "LonelyBookaneer."
Daniel, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book "Your One Word."
Doing the review.
Posting it on your Instagram channel.
I really appreciate the support, man
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
Hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.